herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
zum zweiten teil der überall bekannten
und geliebten show abo löschen aufnehmen
zusammen mit sp heute leben unglaublich
bescheuerten intro erkläre ich mich kurz
fassen zu überdreht also man trägt 3 1
über gesagt man entscheidet wen von den
youtube würde man auch nicht an welche
würde man löschen und mit welchem würmer
aufnehmen und das war auch schon alle
kollegen wechselt dann neigt ja alles
was die youtuber netzhäute andré erst
bei sebastian zimmer und deshalb würde
ich sagen andrea du hast du mir bitte
die ersten drei youtube so werden drei
youtube sturm waffe und felix vorne
lagen
ok sturm fegt wir haben sozusagen die
halbe belegschaft wie boy david
schwierig ein zu löschen weil eigentlich
meine ganz persönliche zumindest
sympathisch ich fange immer mit einem
ekelhaften an
er wird im löschen also ich würde sagen
hätte stur wie heute geschrieben ob ihr
ein video auf in dem er nicht nein
gesagt aber also eigentlich schon nein
gesagt aber er hat halt dann begründet
warum er hat mir erst nicht geantwortet
und deshalb kann ich mit mir
rechtfertigen und vereinbaren dass ich
jetzt tue ich mir das zu zeigen was man
gerade nicht kommen
[Musik]
dann würde ich auch nie mit easy und
abonnieren
also von daher natürlich weil der machte
der macht hofer über bronze
das würde mich gleich noch am meisten
interessieren auch wenn ich wenig
deutschen content schauen wie die
nächsten drei für sebastian machen da
auch wieder was ein bisschen schwieriger
das cloud einmal kranker davon kraft zu
tanken und mehr verstehen
mit 1 von und kreischen echt gemein
fangen will ich auf jeden fall luca es
warum als aus dem grund weil er mal
öffnete löschen
ich würde sagen ich möchte mich einfach
welt am ende warten für konnten besucher
angeboten sagte ich möchte heute
eigentlich nicht löschen damit nicht
dafür die hälfte von einfach die gehört
war ja mal wurde das mache ich einfach
mal anrufen
luca ach du scheiße mit geht um ein
debakel
ok dann würde ich aufnehmen mit ich
wirklich locker aufnehmen und mit und
macht wirklich abonnieren
beim hat einfach so ein spitzen
zuckerschlecken
weil bei mir diabolischen aufnehmen
channels kommt und heute auch bei ftp
upload also gibt hat eine doppel ab
heute verschickt auch sebastian folge ab
fahre ich bin einfach bekannt für
löschen aber auch nimmt und schlaf
perfekt und fashion machen schickt oder
ich mache mich luca wie es zusammen weil
ich einfach mit gerne mit menschen
zusammenarbeitet
dieser ist ich muss gestehen dass ich
mag des videos und kicken lieber show
ist die komplette deswegen würde ich mag
silver von daher macht deutlich ich bin
endlich kompetente kontinenten
information liegt direkt ab jetzt
komplett von war durch erklärt julia
gutjahr zufügen und ok juli ab mutig
diana und der wii u boot wenn jedes mal
eine kleine creed apa red oder ein
bisschen mehr drin wäre weil dann wird
man wenigstens zu löschen würde wen wir
von diesen dreien löschen ich glaube du
der kritik weil ich mit der persönliche
am wenigsten zu tun habe so mit jana
habe ich schon gedreht dann die kenne
ich auch so ein bisschen regen versteht
mir ein verbot mit
deshalb glaube ich wirklich würdig julia
music session lief die hbo texten
arbeiten muss und löschen und deshalb
nehme ich jetzt nicht übermütig gelöscht
von youtube kanal
was sie dann aufnehmen mit wem würde ich
aufnehmen also ich hab einmal als mit
diana aufgenommen hat irgendwie zehnt
haben aber an einen tisch und lässt euch
auch geklärt was mit gewalt die macht
man nicht so viele fahrzeuge bestimmt
ich will mich ändern die entscheidung
einfach abonnieren wien würdig
abonnieren damit das baby abonnieren es
dann nehme ich mit diana hat aber gar
nicht aussuchen können sie bei diana
bonn ihre videos sind halt einfach für
mich so ein bisschen gemacht ja okay zum
schluss perfekt als nächstes folgte um
stuttgart war er so berger und sein
google-konten bürgerlich kennen das ist
so eine armee tun so die sich nackt
aussieht und
fanger und lockt also jetzt um ganz
ehrlich zu sein
hamburg hertha wie chelsea wechselt
zocken der katag ag
ich finde wir haben schon die die größte
art cartel mit linienbus mannschaft hat
im internationalen vergleich haben wir
schon die idee aber die macht in ihrem
typ so was wie wenn jemand frischen
dollars spät dann folgt wie oder wenn
jemand 100 dollar spende dann ja und der
kanadische bewertet fans von ihren
zuschauern so weit ist okay also
dolberger haben wir genug ich will auf
jeden fall erwartet dafür abonnieren das
ist eine neue gute zeit sehr gut aber
ich bin nur gelacht weil der widmung
versehen und allem auch gern mal als da
würde ich glaube ich bei nova löschen
ja okay weil ich weiß nicht ich hatte
bisher nur der gesamtrate gesehen so und
ohne und jetzt oder nie von ihm gesehen
sagen mach jetzt liefern wollte sich für
den gefassten eindruck darüber löschen
und mit hoher wert will ich gerne mal
aufnehmen
mit ihr aufnehmen und danach kann man
vielleicht bist damit er noch über die
kanal strategie reden wir machen noch
zwei schnelle runden weil meine kamera
akku bringt schon eine verklärte blick
hatte ich leider ja
ja genau klinger und apple mit her und
peter klinger network ganz spontan
löschen
[Musik]
ok also abonnieren würde ich auf jeden
fall länger weil so sein content 1 mpeg
noch nicht zur sozialen kritisieren
sondern unterhaltsam geht ein kleiner
löschen oder blätter wie sagten gar
nicht mehr willig kämpft cashen okay
also ist wäre verunreinigung von mir
aber ich würde eher mit knete aufnehmen
also noch freund aber das hätte ich wäre
mir interessantere coladose genre
übergreifend und sowas deshalb denke ich
mal will ich das so machen so will ich
entscheiden so zb den nächsten drei
wochen lang machen wir ja auch schon die
abmahn letzte wollen kathrin sco und
performen
ok also von den dreien ist eine kreativ
auch wichtig weil die schwächsten videos
machen gelöscht werden leute und die
bekommt also den löschen
das fällt mir schwer weil ich an die
gang alle drei eigentlich häufig bleiben
kann tatsächlich also ich hätte kate
nicht öffentlich machen ansprüche gegen
den damals war sieben jahre dann würde
ich sagen es war mit wie möglich
aufnehmen
ich habe mir den kick aber nicht so gut
aufnehmen damit einen song aufnehmen und
würde ja dann schon jackie abonnieren
kardashian hat euch gefallen vielleicht
ist das getan haben das doch gerne mal
einen like da hört ganz schön schwierig
das ganze über internet und sonstig
aufzunehmen deshalb hoffe ich mal jetzt
hab ich gefallen und ihr lasten leichter
so ist jetzt aber schluss